hello everyone and welcome to Game three
well round three of the 2019 I love men
Grande Swiss tournament it's a world
champion Magnus crossing against former
world champion aru stone custom jonov
also a long time second - Vishwa Ratan
Anand a second to Sarah Kerrigan and the
trainer and also second at Fabiana
Caruana
definitely a strong player and it's it's
a very interesting game that really
shows how how complicated the game of
chess can be but before we dive into it
I would just like to have a short shout
out at Chilean performer and singer
hygge who made a new song about chess
it's called tactical there we have it in
the info corner the link to the video
and the song will be the first thing you
will see in the description below here
is a screenshot of one of the one of the
scenes in her video it it's black and
white of course the picking the the
chessboard and the game is I think Amy's
about a very famous chess player who
really liked the sacrifice pieces I'm
sure you all know who we're talking
about there will also be a giveaway in
in the video regarding this player and
well you will learn more about it I
believe tomorrow so I'm not gonna sure
any more information about it but do
check it out I'm very interesting
interested to see what your opinion is a
comment you're welcome to comment on
this video comment on that video and
well it's just like the O cup Blanca
song it's like sort of in James Bond
theme style but you know that maybe
there's just me so feel free to check it
out now let's check out the game cross
and would the white pieces opens with c4
he goes for the English opening with c5
the symmetrical g3 g6 and Bishop to g2
both cousin and cousin Jonathan get
order King side bishops with Knight to
c3 and Knight to c6 so everything is
symmetrical Knight to f3 and now II 6
with h4 my cousin cousin already played
this against a whisk so in Abidjan in
the coda war
blitz tournament and here Wesley went
for h6 but here we have Knight to Knight
to f6 by custom John of deviating from
that game cross and played against
Wesley with d4 by Carlsen in the now
seek after
and e4 Knight characters on d4 and here
a custom John of castles with castles by
Carson and now comes d5 just expanding
in the Centers we've captured by Carson
captures and d5 and now this game has
been reached this position has been
reached once before in a game on each
Geary vs again Wesley so in the Norway
Chess Championship in 2017 where night
sorry Knight captures and c6 was played
but here across and goes for Bishop to
g5 and it is a new move in the position
so already has a move 11 we have a
completely new game the Queen is under
attack you have to decide what to do you
want to go Queen to c7 do you want to
maybe try and trade Queens are nice in
between Moon Knight captures on c3 but
the custom general goes for Queen to a5
just getting the Queen out the way so
the bishop is now you know not doing all
that much more than g5 but at least it's
not a target you don't have any tricks
of Knight captures on c3 with Queen
captures and g5 as the h4 pawn nicely
protects the bishop here so Knights the
b3 attacking cousin Jonas Queen and now
it's already getting a bit crowded here
you don't have all that many good
squares for the Queen so custom jonov
decides to trade here with Knight
captures on c3 offering the Queen trade
Carlsen accepts Knight captures on a
five-night capture son d1 with captures
on c6 and now captures and beat you
grabbing the pawn and now before
[Music]
continuing development first Knights the
e7 width check King to a trade and only
not rook a to c1 so preparing for a nice
roof lifts and it's even though black is
up a pawn cross and has the bishop pair
and it will be very difficult to keep
that pawn for example if rook to b8
just trying to hold onto everything if
you move the bishop you you can just
capture this pawn if you play rook to b8
and rook the c7 is coming and you're
never gonna develop anything you can't
move the do shop you can't move b6
because eight seven falls so there's
just no point trying to trying to hold
on to the point
cousin John over continuous development
the Bishop to d7 he decides to give up
the the b7 pawn and cross and grabs it
back with Bishop captures on b7 and now
rook a to b8 pushing cousins bush
back but first look the c7 a nice rook
lift and only then will you move back
with the bishop
Bishop to b5 going after the e2 pawn and
now Carlson retreats with the defense of
the e to pawn the shop to f3 with a 6
now not allowing the a 7-point to remain
a target and now rook F the c1 nicely
controlling the C file now and it's
black to move cousin John of replace h6
kicks away the Bishop from g5 also
creates some more a breeding room for
the king with the Shabak the e3 and the
now comes rook beat a deed grabbing hold
of the open D file sorry not the F rook
rook a hobby to d8 grabbing hold of the
open D file King G to buy Carlsen
improving the position of the king and
black does the same king to h7 and now
Knight to c6 by cross and attacking the
rook in the Rema nuvaring over to a7
we've looked back to see it offering a
trade now as the rooks are well now and
not connected with nice to a 7 trade
with rook captures rook captures in the
now comes King back to g8 you kinda
can't develop this rook anywhere as it
as it's currently stuck guarding the f7
pawn so custom jonov has to waste a move
returning the King to g8 Knight captures
on b5 now by crossing we have 8 captures
and B 5 and now h5 trying to create some
more weaknesses on the King side of
course you don't want to capture and
mess up your pawn structure so custom
John of pushes g5 and only now rook the
b7 going after the b5 pawn Knight to c4
attacking the bishop trying to mess up
cross and spawn structure here and grab
you know I destroyed his bishop pair but
Bishop to c5 not allowing this trade to
happen and also the rookin f8 is now
under attack we have looked at a 8 and
this is basically the critical moment of
the game well the critical position of
the game so I would ask you to pause the
video here and try to find the best move
for white but it's it's a really tricky
idea it's not just like I want you to
pause the video and you know keep it
paused for a few seconds even a minute
this is the position you want to pause
you know when you have like after a
family dinner you know if for the entire
family to enjoy maybe over
some entity or something and you know
just discuss everything this is just a
very rich position so if any of you
actually did this congratulations as you
know you have a very nice family and but
for those of you who maybe did it alone
I also congratulate you and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
the best move in the position here is
rook captures on b5 so this is one of
those positions where the best move is
just grabbing a pawn
the point is cousin played Bishop to e4
here he wants to control the h7 Square
before before doing rook captures and b5
or something because if the bishop is an
e4 then black will not be able to
capture here due to rook to b8 check so
you will be forced to block with the
bishop and then lose the game but this
in this position here is we will now
present rook captures and b5 is the best
move it just grabs a pawn which is a
very important point and white now has a
past a pawn the problem is you cannot
capture the a pawn after rook captures
an a2 you have so many complications
rook to b8 check came to h7 and now not
Bishop to e4 because Bishop to e4 can be
blocked with f5 first look the b7 going
after the f7 pawn now you play King to
g8 going back and only now here in this
position you go Bishop the e4 and this
is just now a critical position where
you have to see what what can you play
point is f5 f5 doesn't work here but
it's so it's impossible to see this from
that position because here you go Bishop
to d3 you attack the knight here
Knight moves to e5 as you don't want to
give up the knife for nothing and now
rook captures and g7 this is what the
secrets of the position our King
captures in g7 and our Bishop to d4
pinning the night King f6 + f4 wins the
night and now you have two bishops for a
row for example captures captures next
move you lose this guy here and the
bishop air will be of course much
stronger than the rook so the point is
after Bishop to c4 f5 doesn't work this
is the important thing to find and I do
hope you find it you know after your
family
so you have to play Bishop to e5 not
allowing rook to b8 check but then white
just plays rook to d7 and now there's no
stopping rook to DA because you don't
have looked back to a eight the bishop
also covers the age where along with the
h7 square and you can't really allow
this fruity check followed by Bishop to
f8 sure so here you have to play
something rook captures an a2 you go
after the bishop but now you get Bishop
to d3 also also very unfortunate rook
the d2 and now Bishop to b4 and now the
rook has nowhere to go point is if you
go back rook to d1 Bishop to h7 check
wins the rook on d1 so you will have to
bail out with Knight e3 check and after
King to f3 just rope captures on d3
there's nothing better so here white
wins the exchange black is up upon but
white white keeps the exchange and has
has some nice chances here so this is
what the disposition holds it's it's a
very you know poisonous position so to
say so one of those positions were just
route captures and b5 is the best move
but cousin cousin wanted to improve with
Bishop the e4 now of course you cannot
go back with the rook but now cousin
John of takes this opportunity across
and wasted a move he has time to improve
Bishop to e5 now the bishop already
guards the e5 square and now it's a bit
different now you don't you don't really
gain anything by rook captures and b5
because Luke characters on a2 and now
you don't really have a move anymore
rugby is impossible so you would have to
waste more moves to prepare it the
bishop is is here you have to play some
like rook here to here to here and you
don't have all that many moves so here
across and continued bishop the b1 the
guard dat pawn and now Bishop the d6
cousin Gianna wants the trade and he
doesn't want to cause him to keep his
bishop pair cross and of course is not
interested Bishop to e7 blocking the the
rooks influence on the a file and the
now custom jonov also retreats Bishop to
f8 and now cross and plays f4 f4 a nice
expansion
trying to get rid of blacks control of
the of the d5 square which will prove
very handy in the future as you'll see
with G captures on H for an F for G
captures on f4 and now Knight to a5 by
black and here rook back to d7 just
getting in the rook out of harm's way
Knight to c6 now with the double attack
on the bishop and the bishop it back to
f2 now for the moment the a to point is
nicely protected by the bishop on b1
here tonight back at the b4 with a
double attack on the pawn here and this
is what Carlson had in mind and now he
plays this a very interesting point
sacrifice f5 so black can't really
afford to ignore this so a cosmic
general decides to capture this we have
pawn captures an f5 now doubling black
spawns here and now you no longer have
the east exponent control the d5 square
only now Carlson retreats and now the
night it doesn't have the d5 square so
the night unless it wants to go all the
way back to c6 is currently stuck there
here the situation on the clock is 10
minutes both of them with Bishop to e7
this is more 38 so two more moves need
to be made before reaching time control
and hereafter Bishop to e7 custom Gianna
was down to some five minutes cross and
still had 10 minutes on the clock
Bishop the e1 now creating some tactics
here as the knight is under attack but
cosmic jonov just shows that there are
no no no good discoveries here and
pushes f4 and now there is one more move
to be made to reach or move 40 and cross
and really should make the most
complicated move so custom general would
have to waste as much time as possible
as he is under a minute so what do you
do here across and went rook to d7 he
created an attack against the bishop on
e7 a but custom jonov very quickly
played Bishop to f8 and now both of them
reach time control additional time was
granted their clocks and okay King to f1
but Carlson and here cosmic Janna really
started to think he spent some 17
minutes in this position and it was not
not an easy position he's up upon but
cross and still has the bishop pair okay
for the moment it's an inactive bishop
pair but still you know it they control
a lot of squares here so not really
although they are on the
first rank they are covering a lot of
squares and the very active rook on d7
so you have to play at the precise moves
yeah you cannot capture the pawn right
away if you capture it then the problem
is Bishop to e4 you get this maneuver
while attacking the rook look to see it
and now rush up to d5 with an attack on
the night and the f7 squared this would
be this would be bad for black but
custom Jono goes to Bishop to c5 instead
so after those 17 minutes Carlson
continues now rook to b7 goes after the
b5 pawn but now the pawn can be captured
just Knight captures an a2 this is what
caused him jonna plays as Bishop to d5
no longer comes with an attack on the
roof so there is no point in in playing
it we have rook captures on b5 by
Carlson attacking the bishop and now
Bishop to d4 we have rook to b3 keeping
control of the c3 square both with the
bishop and rook and not allowing this
night to join the game King to g7 custom
jonov improves the position of the King
and now rook to d3
pushing the bishop back while still
keeping an eye on the c3 square bishop
to f6 and now Bishop to d2 attacking the
f4 pawn and now ripped a for custom
jonov defends it and now rook back to d7
just increasing the activity of the rook
as black still has to figure out how to
get how to activate his pieces on the
Queen side with King back to g8 not
allowing this this well the King to be
on the same file as the rook and now
rook back to c7 again with the double
control on the c3 square we have looked
to d4 by custom jonov and now Carlsen
really has to make a decision here doing
a really nice job keeping this night and
Bay and if you don't if you do something
silly
well you just lose the night so here
custom Jono says okay we can trade or
you can play some like King e1 try and
keep an eye on this Bishop but then I
have fish of the h4 check King 31 and
they're now just night to be 4 you
cannot trade even trade here as the
there's a pin on the D file here so
Carlsen isn't interested in this but
there also is Bishop to d3 which
keeps the game going as it it avoid it
avoid straights for example now if night
before years the night is activated but
you just go brush up the c3 and you lose
the game is black you cannot keep an eye
on both the night the rook and if the
rook even had a place to move also the
bishop on f6 so this would be of course
winning for white so Bishop to d3 is a
very interesting move for white but
across and instead went for Bishop
captures Sunday 2 he decided to trade a
pair of bishops we have blue capture
sandy - and now Bishop captures on f7
with check King to f8 and now - hobble
back to c4 just retreating with the
bishop now the rook can also move
doesn't have to keep an eye on it
Bester back to g5 and now we have King
to have to do so here we have an endgame
the mature on the board is equal and the
bishops are of opposite colors rook the
c2 by custom jonov and now King to f3
we have rook the c3 trek kinky for my
cross and marching the king of the board
and here custom jonov just played f3
were Carlsen captured and it was in this
position unmoved 55 that the players
agreed to a draw why did they agree to
it row well custom jonov can just play
rook e3 check you cannot go here to keep
an eye on your phone you have to move
back now rook captures with the check
King g6 or g6 doesn't matter and even
though it seems like black could be in
trouble not really you are never getting
rid of this pawn the dark square bishop
just the defense it so the light square
bishop can't really help the rope you're
not gonna be giving your look for that
pawn or the bishop and well with the two
very active pieces that custom jonov can
always just push the white king back and
that there are no made threats here so
this is a completely wrong endgame but
yeah after he captures an f3 they agree
to a draw as so a really tough game an
excellent game but both of them and
other than that moment where Crossan had
the option of going for that
well insane engine line that I believe
no human can even spot even if he had
all the time in the world
but yeah I just show you how difficult
and games are how important it is to
study end games and
how how rich the you know the entire
endgame area is so you know sometimes
someone will tell you and games are
boring I don't feel like studying in
games this is what an end game can you
know can hold and try try to you know
deceive you that no there's nothing
there so yeah really really complicated
game I enjoyed it I do hope you enjoyed
it as well and it's I know it seems like
we're showing only one game per day and
the for a moment we've shown three
Karlsson games and there are so many
other games being played but I didn't
have all that much time I only got back
from Zagreb like an hour ago so I
decided to show this one as I know you
guys always want to check out Carlson's
games but tomorrow I have a bit more
time so I will try to do a maybe maybe
even three to four videos we'll see so
keep on suggesting as I always enjoy
your hashtag suggestions and well they
always give me some good ideas on what
show so that being said I do check out
the tactical by hygge I really enjoyed
both both the music ended the video it's
really really well done so I hope you
enjoyed that as well I will I would like
to thank Pollock slow-mo burnt fighter
Rita
Benjamin both world Grammy Sims and
Simon Johansen for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the isle of
man chess tournament chicken company or
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the world so thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day